hier sur france 2 il y avait caché
investigations le magazine d'élise lucet
or là restez avec nous parce qu'il ya
plein de choses à dire là dessus et le
thème d'hier était coton l'envers de nos
t-shirts et après une enquête dans les
usines de coton en ouzbékistan une
journaliste de cash investigations
sandrine rigaud a eu un rendez-vous dans
un café à paris avec le patron belge une
usine de confession ouzbeks
elle s'est fait passer pour une
acheteuse françaises intéressées par ces
produits et la discussion commence sur
le travail forcé en ouzbékistan regardez
sans déconner ça me rappelle un peu la
scène dans la vérité si je regardais ça
jours en raison de la situation
le patron pense s'adresser à une cliente
alors qu'il parle à une journaliste qui
justement est entré en ouzbékistan avec
un visa touristique qui elle aussi a été
arrêté mais comme la journaliste en
question n'est pas censé être une
journaliste mais une clientèle continue
d'écouter cette histoire l'air de rien
comme une cliente en espérant juste que
le patron de l'apa a démasqué comme
journaliste vous comprenez le petit
malaise
voilà alors fanées marc parent ça
ensuite pendant l'enquêté les uc s'est
penché sur une marque de prêt-à-porter
qui appartient à l'ancien carrefour
c'est le l'extrême dont tout le monde a
parlé et les dirigeants de la marque ont
refusé les demandes d'interview élise
lucet s'est rendu à une réunion
d'actionnaires pour poser quelques
questions et apparemment elle n'était
pas la bienvenue
nous sommes allés dans des filatures au
bangladesh qui utilise du coton ouzbeks
qui travaillent pour vous donc deux
fesses nues quand on voudrait que ce
retrait
je pense qu'on a bien merci beaucoup
monsieur place à mes trimestres bédié
merci
que les fonctionnaires
alors ça a beaucoup fait réagir sur les
réseaux sociaux dans cash investigations
les actionnaires de carrefour traquer
les us et de vendu de gauchistes parce
qu'elle point que le travail des enfants
dans leur usine au bangladesh
à gerber les actionnaires qui insultent
copieusement élise lucet sont vraiment
répugnant
je suis choqué après il y aura un
extrait je vous dis qui m'a pas beaucoup
plus hier je vais vous montrer ce n'est
pas celui-là mais si on est un autre
dans un magasin je voulais absolument
vous montrez vous l'avoir l'a dit
également des téléspectateurs mais vous
ici autour de la table est-ce que les
méthodes de cash investigations hier
pour ça est ce que vous comprenez les
insultes ou est-ce que vous êtes choqués
que les téléspectateurs des insultes et
j'ai adoré c'est un des meilleurs et
j'aurais fait choqué des injures des
insultes elle fait son boulot elle ose
intervenir parce qu'on ne répond pas à
ses demandes
je trouve que c'était un modèle de
journalisme et j'ai appris plein de
choses qui n'est pas d'accord avec
gilles qui jean michel bouat moi parce
que voilà comme d'habitude c'est tout
dans l'artificiel tout dans la la
propagande mais dans la vie quand ils
invectivent le patron de carrefour lui
apprend du très poliment c'est les
actionnaires qui étaient là qu'il
trouvait qu'elle avait rien à [ __ ] là
parce que c'était pas son rôle d'être là
qu'ils ont dit dégage puis il avait des
vrais sujets dont il voulait parler et
moi je mets au défi à ce moment là elise
lucet de fer à kashan indications sur
france télévisions voilà demander où va
l'argent pour les productions voilà mal
c'est l'espace et gamal de poursuivre il
y ce dossier des couloirs une place au
monde répondait finalement ne répondait
qu'elle soit pas se poursuivre elle même
là on a que possible d'élever berne dans
les points castrais de les cadets qui
souhaite avoir a dit toujours notre
société capitaliste ultralibérale et ses
dérives c'est bien mais c'est toujours
la même chose c'est toujours la mise en
scène
alors il faut boycotter car faut il faut
boycotter lidl il faut boycotter free
c'est tellement toujours manichéen chez
elle fait les bons temps quand on arrête
on est on étend le programme est quoi
alors la nuit c'est noir le l'hiver
c'est froid
excusez moi mais c'est toujours des
lieux communs et c'est toujours en
floride mais ça change quoi
alors j'ai relu curieux il faut dénoncer
non moi ce qui m'énerve le plus vraiment
et c'est à chaque fois pareil en cash à
l'investigation c'est que finalement
tous les sites tout le monde reprend la
phrase qui concerne les français donc un
magasin français alors qu'il ya un super
reportage sur l'addition des gens qui
sont exploités en ouzbékistan et
j'ai en afghanistan est évidemment au
bangladesh
et finalement on retient que ça et on
retient que la phrase un petit peu
choqués on oublie carrément tout le
travail qui est fait à côté un reportage
était vachement bien retient que ça
c'est voilà exactement mais l'erreur moi
j'avais tué quelqu'un qui vous a donné
la parole en moi effectivement avant
kate était remarquable sur moi je savais
pas quand nous existons réquisitionné
toute la population y compris les
médecins pour aller travailler dans les
champs et évidemment les enfants donc ça
c'est ma peur ne le savait pas en
revanche mais toi tu sais c'est la
première minute et demie où on dit et
autrefois casse investigations c'était
ça et ça se fait ça se passe exactement
comme un polar
ça fait c'est une mise en scène que
l'émission ne méritait pas sa nouvelle
émission est au dessus de ça ne devrait
pas faire ça je voudrais d'autres
extraits voile extraits sur carrefour et
je trouve qu'elle a fait voilà la fait
son boulot après on aime ou on n'aime
pas ses méthodes mais il ya la
journaliste d'actes de cash
investigations sandrine rigaud qui est
aussi aller dans un magasin de vêtements
pour enfants pour poser des questions
sur les ai dit les étiquettes ou écrites
la mention coton responsable et la voix
off
c'est un petit peu moqué des vendeuses
et mine de rien elle les pauvres sont
croyants à savoir l ont elles ont un
travail et c'est vrai que si demain ces
bandeaux sont reconnus par le patron et
si elle se retrouve demain au chômage à
cause de ce 2e heure de ce reportage
franchement ça ça nous embêterait tous
regardé ça voilà les pauvres vendeuse
est derrière et leur remettre un coup
alors qu'elles n'y sont pour rien
regarder si on fait ça fait 6 4
c'est en fait c'est l'équité pour vous
respecte et qu'on utilise une fois qu'un
haut responsable éco responsable c'est
encore le pas
plus
bon alors c'est bio ou pas bio en voie
d'être bio éco écolo responsable c'est
sans pesticides mais y en a quand même
un peu mais beaucoup moins
alors alors alors je vous dirai donc il
y en avait une autre juste avant la
pauvre aussi qu'ils savaient pas trop et
qui essayait d'expliquer voilà c'était
c'était très gênant à ça c'était
vraiment une prise d'otage de ces de ces
pauvres vendeurs et vendeuses que moi en
plus j'ai été vendeuse dans un magasin
de chaussures mais ça c'est pas très
important mais est important c'est la
qualification devant 2 c'est de vendre
le produit savoir où il a été convenu il
a été fabriqué par si les actionnaires
les machins c'est pas ton boulot à redon
moi ça me gêne pas d'accord à ce que l
sont floutés et parce que c'est le prix
les patrons et des reconnaissent alors à
me dire j'ai kit rue mais oui mais elle
suit après et caen et quand les employés
sont victimes des pattes non elle suit
c'est vrai quoi c'est normal et patrons
là il va être au chômage les deux
petites là je pense qu'elle suivra laïcs
et les fusées royal elle va dire faut
les reprendre arrêté la connaissant le
suivre à dire il s'agit pas de les
mettre au chômage
en revanche peut-être juste de leur dire
bah il ya un moment donné quand vous
vendez essaie à tout petit peu
d'apprendre ce que vous vendez et si
c'est si vous savez de quoi vous vous
êtes dans un restaurant bat là-bas si on
vous dit qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ce plat
là bas vous apprenez les phrases
bêtement par coeur et vous savez ce
qu'ils avaient dit vous êtes bien c'est
un produit qui est un petit peu plus
cher quand vous achetez un produit
calibré way back est sage un petit peu
ce qui est dense et après on est passé
l'enquète sur les champs de coton sa
fédé ça fait des siècles ddd des
décennies que c'est un endroit où les
gens seront exploitées on le sait et
fille commençait bien de lui dont celle
de le dire dans quinze jours va faire
quoi les baskets nike qui sont faites en
chine par les enfants
je regarde tout le monde le sait pas ce
qu'en pensent les téléspectateurs par
christian que vous pensez montagne
visiblement il ya effectivement un bon
travail d'investigation effectivement
après les vrais truisme les choses qu'on
dénonce comme le dit benjamin que tout
le monde sait même pas forcément de la
pertinence mais en tout cas il faut
essayer de vous informer le maximum de
personnes
mais des fois c'est très maladroit alors
regardez la question les méthodes de
cash investigations choqué car ne sent
pas sauter ça va tu as une voix de plus
les téléspectateurs sont plutôt d'accord
avec gilles verdez et avec mathieu doit
maudire sa première fois que vous êtes
d'accord tous les deux bon